are you okay
yeah i'm just waiting for it to
cooperate with me
hi i'm aaron i am jerry and we are test
betting our new old
resurrected podcast called dank ass
stubs
which you can check out on soundcloud
listed somewhere i'll put it somewhere
you'll find it somewhere you'll see
[ __ ] frame it might be between us it
might be if it is yeah if it is and i do
decide to put it between us we're going
to look like geniuses right now yeah so
uh that's that's the link there yeah and
if once you are listened
and seasoned in some dank ass stubbory
what i i just know
you shut up no keep talking okay once
you have listened to the podcast and if
you want to contribute give us ideas for
topics and and content and things that
you want to hear out of the podcast go
ahead and email us at dankasstubs
gmail.com or leave a comment on the
soundcloud track
and we will see you at the movies yeah
or somewhere we'll see we'll see you on
the street we'll see you i will find you
wherever the recording devices are
if you want to hear us dish then come on
over if you like long-form content
people talking about [ __ ] for a long
time you
put that on in the background while you
do something more important perhaps
hopefully and i promise the audio levels
will improve they will we'll get the
hang of this garage band had to update
and become confusing thanks to annual
financial support from viewers like you
thank you and remember stay dank is it
working is it working is it working it
looks like it's working let's just go
for it and remember kids stay dank
in school
you